this is an important announcement
especially if you live in Los Angeles I
am shooting my special Wednesday
December 14th at the dynasty typewriter
theater here in Los Angeles uh tickets
are available on my website right now at
ryansickler.com and here's the deal
if you use code sickler and I'm telling
you specifically you all because you all
are the die hards if you use code
sickler you're getting half off your
tickets all right so uh we're gonna do
two shows Wednesday December 14th go
snag those tickets up now I want to
loaded house let's have a great time
bringing an end to this night pants
Nation Tour for the special that you
guys will see uh very soon hopefully
Chicago I'll be there November 11th and
12th Grand Rapids Michigan December 9th
and 10th get your tickets to those shows
and all shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all your
social medias
um listen
all seriousness here this is episode 200
and I want to just really say thank you
so much I know this show makes a
difference okay I I get flooded with
emails and messages and just being out
on the road and you guys coming up to me
and telling me that this show has saved
your life or it's the reason you started
therapy or might even be the reason you
connected with family again I I just
want to say thank you so much 200
episodes is a big deal and um I'm very
grateful so
um if you're watching out there on
YouTube please hit that subscribe button
and if you gotta have more then check
out the patreon it's called the Honeydew
with y'all and I tell you every week I
highlight the low lights with you all
and you all have the wildest [ __ ]
stories every week I am blown away by
the [ __ ] and the inbox is ridiculous all
right so if you or someone you know has
a story that has to be heard please
submit it the Honeydew podcast gmail.com
um if you sign up for a year you're
saving over a month it's only five bucks
there's no other levels layers any of
that [ __ ] all right
um I'm on tour right now go to
ryancicler.com for all your tickets
there you go oh Chicago November 11th
and 12th and Grand Rapids uh December
9th and 10th all right so Chicago we're
doing Friday Saturday Grand Rapids same
thing all right that's the biz you guys
know we do over here we highlight the
low lights I always say these are the
stories behind the storytellers and I am
very excited to have this guest on today
first time here on the Honeydew ladies
and Gentlemen please welcome Jody Sweden
welcome to the honeymoon hey hello hello
very excited to have you here why thank
you I am very excited to be here I am I
really want uh honeydew right now
because it's just I actually really do
like I do I do yeah these are all fan
submitted pictures
yeah right and then there's like the
spoon someone nobody wants it nobody
wants nobody wants I actually do like it
it's all right yeah well then you're
definitely welcome here why thank you
um thank you for being our guest on
episode 200. my pleasure I didn't
realize I was going to be here for such
a a big occasion yeah we are excited I
hope I don't make it uh I hope I don't
[ __ ] this up you're not gonna [ __ ] it up
um all right before we get into whatever
we're gonna get into please plug and
promote everything and anything you
would like yes yes yes
um let's see I have my podcast never
thought I'd say this uh which has five
seasons out we're taking a short Hiatus
and then we're coming back the beginning
of next year and we're gonna start doing
two hour monthly specials
um so you can check that out never
thought I'd say this at Jody Sweetin
across all socials it's s-w-e-e-t-i-n
um what else am I working on right now
I've got a couple holiday movies coming
out a Hallmark movie coming out October
28th uh and then a lifetime Christmas
movie merry Swiss Miss coming out on
November
fifth I want to say oh yeah November 5th
uh yeah so I've got a couple of movies
premiering
um I am hoping to Direct One either
later this year or beginning of next uh
I am working on some comedy stuff I do a
monthly show called the sdsc show that's
all online we have fans from all over
the world it's stand-ups and we do
comedy and games and all kinds of fun
stuff so check that out too sdscshow.com
um and it's like fun ridiculous comedy
uh so yeah I've I'm sure I've got other
things that I will remember I'm working
on a theater project right now
um with a group of uh of incredible uh
uh people and yeah so I'm I'm just kind
of trying to dig into some creative
stuff right now it's exciting very good
yeah and I love that you um you know I
forget that you work with Saget so of
course you have comedy roots and I do
that's how I met you I met you at The
Comedy Store just about a couple weeks
ago yeah like a week ago yeah oh my so
much life happens in a week now but yeah
I think it was like a week ago yeah and
you and your friend came backstage and
hung out you guys were super cool and uh
yeah I'm really grateful that you came
I'm I'm really grateful to be here I
always love trying to help people and
share my story and maybe make it funny
and let's talk about your story because
I I want to know yeah everything I wanna
this is a life story episode so start
where the beginning where are you
originally from Mom Dad brother sisters
um I was born here in Los Angeles I was
born uh actually at downtown USC county
hospital
I was born to a woman named Barbara who
was in jail at the time I was born is
that right yes wait so were you
delivered in prison on whatever floor of
the USC county hospital the one downtown
the General Hospital that won that was
where I was born so they took her out of
jail did they take them out right and
then you're hold on there this is not
trust you're gonna I'm not even kidding
you're gonna need like a notepad and my
family tree is sort of a bush that's it
like interconnected and so yeah just
yeah yeah yeah it's and it's it's all in
my book unsweetened which came out in
2009 uh and I keep getting asked if I'm
gonna write another book and I don't
know there's something stirring in my
head that I might so anyway
um
I was born uh to a woman named Barbara
uh at USC county hospital uh I was taken
home by um a friend of hers and a friend
of um the person of of my biological
dads
um her name was Cindy
um my biological dad uh was in jail at
the time John excuse me he was in prison
at the time he was at Soledad prison
um for bad checks and drugs uh he was
sent to a Maximum Security Prison uh
because the minimum security was
overcrowded he was supposed to be moved
I was about nine months old I believe
when this happened uh he was supposed to
be moved a couple weeks later uh and a
prison riot broke out and he was stabbed
in the heart and killed no uh yes so
um he was obviously out of the picture
um but his family had uh taken me in my
mom was still in jail sort of in and out
why was she in jail [ __ ] drugs and bad
checks they all kind of got wrapped up
in some stupid [ __ ]
um and
you know I I so that was where I started
um and then Cindy the woman who brought
me home from the hospital
uh who is my biological Dad's cousin
okay Cindy's dad Sam
uh is my adopted dad okay
Sam my dad would come and check on Cindy
and his ex-wife who had some mental
health issues and make sure that
everything was okay there were groceries
there were you know he sort of was was
in and out he and my mom had already
been married and they wanted kids and
um I was my mom at the time was not able
to take care of me and so they wound up
adopting me so
um technically I'm my my dad's my dad's
kids from his first marriage are by
Blood my cousin but by adoption my half
siblings okay right so that's sort of
the weird little yeah
um sometimes you need a map but um I
came my my parents my mom and dad Sam
and Janice
um
are wonderful wonderful people and I was
I I fell into an incredible life that I
I know I would not have had otherwise
um I could have very easily been in the
system I could have very easily
um just wound up bouncing from house to
house foster care um which was what my
biological mom did she was on her own by
the time she was 15. so I was fortunate
I wound up in an incredibly loving home
with wonderful parents and uh I was
bright I was I was smart
um and so you know my my dad saw that my
mom wasn't able to take care of me they
adopted me and um my mom was a
stay-at-home mom my dad was a
superintendent at a gypsum plant in Long
Beach Harbor which is what drywall is
made out of he started working there
when he was like 17 18 years old and
worked his way up to superintendent
my dad came from uh he was born in 1934
in Oklahoma
came from a no electricity no running
water home wow with eight brothers and
sisters and lived in the Central Valley
as a migrant Farm worker as a kid he was
an Okie migrant in the 40s and worked
his way up and became superintendent of
a gypsum plant with very limited
education so I I my dad
um
my dad has done a lot and seen a lot and
my mom was an incredible stay-at-home
mom and she
would she got me reading she got me
doing all of these creative things that
I just love to do and I really Excel
that and then you know by the time I was
three I was reading books
um and able to memorize things and loved
performing and loved dancing and
told my mom I wanted to be a performer I
wanted to be a modeler that was what I
called it mommy I want to be a modeler
and what was it that you saw or what
what resonated with you that planted
that seed for you I loved I mean I was
the kid I was an only child growing up I
was the kid who would
find a harmonica and run into the middle
of the room while my mom and grandma and
Aunt were having a conversation and be
like and now
like stop my feet doing the whole thing
twirl around and be like and thank you
and then I'd leave and you're out right
so this letter I was just let her have
it my first dance recital I was like one
row back and the [ __ ] in front of me
was like [ __ ] it up so I was like
look you got and I pushed her out of the
way and I got it to the front so my mom
was like maybe she likes to perform okay
uh and and was like you know what the
hell like okay put you in some print ads
and maybe a couple commercials you know
what's gonna come of it and um and now
I'm 40 years old and I've been in this
business since I was four off and on I
mean I've I've had stints in like you
know quote unquote the normal world I
worked in drug and alcohol treatment for
a while
um I worked at a school for a while did
you yeah doing what uh my actually my
undergrad degree is in liberal studies
with an emphasis in elementary education
and and a history minor so I was going
to be an elementary school teacher
that's what I got my my bachelor's in
and I worked at a school
um after I graduated
very nice yeah so there's my my story
has a lot of offshoots and a lot of
different well let's jump back to four
because you said at four you actually
get a do you actually get a paid job I
did I was doing commercials I was doing
uh I did a Sizzler commercial I did an
Oscar Meyer commercial
um The Sizzler commercial actually went
so well uh there was a little boy that
was there who was supposed to be doing
it and they had me do it and then I just
took over for him and so they actually
called me Jody in the commercial because
they didn't even have a name written for
me it was Brad I think was the original
I wound up doing this all you can eat
fried shrimp commercial
oh my God let me tell you if I never ate
fried shrimp again for like [ __ ]
years after that um but it ruined me at
four against fried shrimp and Sizzler
really um but although let's I mean for
real like Sizzler really ruined me on
Sizzler so
um yeah but at four I did a commercial
for their all you can eat shrimp uh and
BB dno which was a huge ad company at
the time that worked for them uh gave me
a dog because this it was such a
successful commercial you got a nice dog
so much to it they wanted to know what I
what in the world I could possibly want
that would make me happy they asked my
mom and she was like she really wants a
dog what kind of dog do you get it's a
little Lhasa Apso we named her I named
her Lacey uh after Lee Lacey who was the
director of the commercial
um yeah so that was nice you have the
hair all the way down no we kept her
short and like yeah I feel but that dog
would spend she spent time outside more
than I'd like and I I feel bad about
that like my dad was not the dog person
that my mom and I have forced him to be
now
so
um but anyway uh yeah at four years old
I did that I started working and then I
got
uh a guest appearance on a show called
Valerie I don't know if you remember
that show with Valerie Harper yeah and
uh I was playing the next door neighbor
I was playing her niece so I was playing
Pamela pool I was Mrs Poole's niece
um and she comes over and hurts her back
and then suddenly the three boys have to
take care of me Jason Bateman Jeremy
Licht and um oh my gosh I feel terrible
I'm forgetting the third one's name
anyway uh Danny no
Danny something anyway
um and how old are you at this time uh
not I like almost five oh wow you're
still four still four almost five and
um I did this episode of the show
and
The Producers it was the same producers
that were creating Full House at the
time it was Miller Boyette who have done
Happy Days and delivered and Shirley and
Valerie and all of that yeah uh and they
loved what I did with Pamela Poole uh
and they cast me as Stephanie I never
auditioned for the part no way
um it was they knew from seeing me do
that that it was exactly what they
wanted and um I was one of the first
people cast and that was it and from
that moment on you know my life became
very very different
so tell me about it how are you I mean
you're five and you're a man Full House
at five yeah I mean and you know Full
House was not successful the first at
season we did not yeah right oh yeah I
didn't know that critics hated our show
critics have always hated our show it's
not we realized like look we're we're
not doing this for critics we're doing
this for our fans and
um once we got families watching like
after those first 13 episodes
um
it started really growing and then it
became like a really really successful
show here's a while over eight years
okay so you starting at five Looking
Back Now as an adult when do you
realize like this thing's turning into
something much bigger I don't know that
I ever did it never people weren't
stopping you look they were that was the
thing people were stopping me on the
street
I'd go to like a mall appearance I
remember a mall appearance in Des Moines
Iowa that they I had to dress up as a
boy and escape from because too many
people showed up at the mall and the
fire marshal had to shut it down it's
like 10 000 people so it's a small no
and they had to sneak me out in a police
car
yeah and like it was ridiculous and I
think about these things and I'm like
that was my life like at you know 10 or
11 and I remember it was on the news the
Des Moines news and I was so sad because
people were angry
that I wasn't there the angry that I
left and I remember I as a kid I was
like but I had to like they told me I
had you know and I was so upset that
I couldn't have my side of this like
they they couldn't hear my side
um you know I had I I knew it was a big
thing but I never I also lived a very
grounded life at home I didn't grow up
in La proper I grew up right outside of
LA and Orange County
um my dad still worked at a gypsum plant
for a while and then he retired and then
he was a handyman
um you know my mom was with me on set
all the time she was like you know with
me every day drove me to set if I had to
travel she was there she was you know I
guess my manager
um she was the one that was with me all
the time
um and so my mom and I had a really
close relationship growing up
um but I wanted to I loved doing what I
did and my parents always said like
if you love this we'll support you if
you stop loving this and you don't want
to do this like we you know tell us
um my parents were never like
pushy go you know go perform for us
um I think my mom I mean I was in
pageants when I was little and stuff my
mom definitely loved
um the performance the dress-up aspect
all that but she was never like
the pushy stage mom she was like let me
just blend into the background I just
want to make sure my kid's okay
um and that kept me really normal you
know I went to public school I had
normal the whole time okay yeah I had
normal friends you know most of the a
lot of the friends at my birthday
parties were just kids from school but
how would you do that what was your work
week like because I'm sure you're you're
such a child that they've got to protect
you and not work you what god
well the first season I seem to remember
we did schooling on set and stuff and
then we'd work three weeks and have a
week off so then I'd go to regular
school and stuff but
but later on in the seasons and I can't
remember exactly when I want to say
like
fourth grade maybe third fourth grade
um maybe even earlier they started
letting me go to school in the morning
so I we would work a four day week uh
Mondays I would be in school as a
regular day Tuesdays and Wednesdays I
would go to school till lunch my mom
would pick me up and at that time
traffic was doable that you could drive
from Orange County to Culver City in you
know 45 minutes and and make it at noon
um
right so like God bless those times uh
and I was able to go to school in the
morning and then I would go rehearse in
the afternoon do rehearsal and run
through and then you know homework in
the car or whatever and and then
Thursday and Friday are tape days I did
schooling on set or I could Bank hours
on rehearsal days so that those would
count towards the you know if I had a
big episode to film or something on
Thursday or Friday so it was a balance
of both
and I am so grateful for that because I
always had a foot in normal life my
parents were normal people my parents we
didn't they didn't give a [ __ ] about
going to Hollywood parties and you know
it was like just a regular existence
yeah and it was a break from
the crazy of you know going going all
the time and are you exclusive to Full
House during that time are you allowed
to do anything else no during that time
floss took up most of my most of my time
because
um you know we shot like nine months out
of the year we at that time network
shows were doing 24 to 26 episodes six
or seven right where it wasn't this
Netflix like you know limited series
eight
um but you know it was 24 to 26 episodes
a season so you were working three weeks
you were off a week you were off for a
little while at the holidays and then
sort of late spring early summer you had
off and then you went back to work so
you know it was that was the schedule
and that was what I did for eight years
eight years so from five to about
thirteen thirteen yeah and as you're
getting older like
are you what what are you seeing
differently in the industry as you get
older like we hear about all these kids
who are child actors who get taken
advantage of right but you got your mom
there you know like I was really really
fortunate in that
everyone on our set our entire cast Bob
Dave John Lori
um our directors our producers everyone
was kind
you know
um at least to the kids I mean I'm sure
there was [ __ ] that happens at work
you know whatever but it was a real
family so the adults on set looked out
for us if they noticed like we were kind
of they were like hey can we take a five
can we you know oh good so space they
were aware of us we spent time together
outside of just work we were a family
unit and still are which I'm so grateful
for but you know it was not
um like yeah there were things that I
missed and I'm I'm sort of going through
this moment right now in my life where
I'm like okay well it wasn't all it
wasn't all good and it wasn't all bad
like there were some really wonderful
things about it and I had a great
experience compared to some other people
um but there were definitely things that
it took away from my childhood and the
anonymity that I lost at such a young
age and things like that okay so let's
you know processing that too but
I'm just I I grew up in an environment
that we were laughing all the time
comedy was a huge piece of my life and
how I lived day to day was around
stand-up comedians and listening to them
and just having fun with them
um and so I'm I I am so glad that I had
that because I know I had a very
different experience than a lot of kids
in this business
and it really shaped me for sure
so what um
what do you start seeing like what age
are you exposed to drugs alcohol I mean
I have people sit across from me talk to
me about six seven eight and they're not
in entertainment oh that so this [ __ ]
comes fast out here yeah but you know
what I entered all of that completely
away from the world of entertainment is
that right oh yeah I was not around it
um you know maybe I would have like a
glass of champagne I think we'd go to
The Palm restaurant and you know at like
13 when I would get to go out with all
the adults after a show we'd go to the
palm and I'd finally that eighth season
would get included and like I'd get a
glass of champagne but you know they'd
pour it for a 13 year old
um yeah uh but as far as that kind of
stuff we didn't it that wasn't the
environment of our set that wasn't the I
mean you know
it just wasn't around us they were
conscientious of of the kids I started
getting into that in high school in high
school with you know other stupid kids
after the show so 13 it ends 13 it ends
and eighth grade 13 it ends eighth grade
and I start high school I start high
school I turn I turned 13 because
um
I was 13 when I started High School I
was a year ahead of everybody I'd skip
to grade in elementary
um so I was younger than people uh I was
now a full-time student I was in a
theater program a musical theater
program the Orange County High School
for the Arts
um but I now was also like just a normal
kid
and
now all of a sudden that routine that
kept me really busy is gone
and
um it was a huge adjustment like there
was something that was nice about it
where it was like there was nothing
extra expected of me I just didn't
have to go anywhere all the time I
didn't have to I could just be at school
um but at the same time
you know I started real like realizing
okay I don't I don't know how I fit into
this I don't know I just I just want to
be normal like everyone else
um are you playing sports are you wasn't
playing sports I was in theater
um my my you know my regular school
hours went until like 1 30 p.m and then
from 1 30 to about 5 P.M every day we
did our theater program so again I still
had long days I was still involved in
theater and performance
um but I was a kid too I was in high
school and I was doing stupid [ __ ] that
high school kids do
um except for the fact that you know
addiction runs in my biological history
and so for me when I pick up a drink it
does something very different than it
does for everyone else and how quickly
did you realize that I realized that
pretty early on I remember I seem to
remember it like 15 writing some overly
dramatic poem which I know now oh God if
I want to find those [ __ ] books so
bad because I know there's like
ridiculous poems of you know that need
to be on mortified have you ever
listened to that podcast oh no but
that's a great idea yeah more to find is
just people getting up and read it's
brilliant
it's so brilliant because it's poignant
and it's hilarious and you know at that
time when they wrote that they were
right
there's ones about people like I'm in
love with the waiter at Olive Garden and
I know he loves me too and he you know
and like that stupid [ __ ] when you're
drunk you're like okay
for real like the dude of the Froyo
Place loved me right you're like 11 with
a stupid Crush but like I know somewhere
in those books I I wrote down like that
I was an alcoholic it did yeah 15. yeah
yeah yeah I knew I I knew like for me it
was there was no off switch so it runs
biologically did your parents your have
did they have issues yeah both of them
yeah but as far as I know my my mom did
uh and my dad had issues with alcohol
and then it just runs it throughout that
biological family which I know of
because I know through my adopted dad I
can ask you know um uh relatives so in
that regard I'm I was fortunate but I
think
and I've talked about this before there
was like a part of me that because that
was
gosh was getting very raw today um
because
that was what I knew about them that was
the story I had been told that was my
way to connect with them and that was
that was the story that I told myself I
see that I that that was what I was
um and I think it you know wasn't I mean
we'll get to that point after I had my
daughter but um the Forgiveness took me
a long time to for find the forgiveness
in myself
uh and in my my biological mom I think a
lot of adoptees feel like that that even
if they know they wound up in a much
better situation like somehow there's
that level of
rejection yeah I wasn't good enough
right right right
um and so I had to I think that was a
big piece of what I was working through
honestly and I always say that I would
have had struggles with alcohol and
drugs
regardless of being in television I know
for myself the way that I react to it
had nothing to do with the fact that I
was on TV that was all an internal thing
that would have happened regardless
but because I was on TV everyone knew
about it I see so you know what I mean
it was like it it and and and it added a
layer of obvious weirdness to my life
that I'm sure I was seeking to figure
out with drugs and alcohol
um so you know it it was around 13 I
started drinking and then you know in
high school I was like I would drink in
class I was in class oh yeah yeah you do
that I just have a big coffee mug um
that was like Kahlua and coffee and I
would just sit in class and and drink it
but I was getting good grades and
teachers liked me
and so I was able to
um
you know I could I could play it off I
could act
um I could pretend and nobody knew I
could keep up this facade and that was
something that made you think that's
ballsy to bring it into class
there was something I I have always uh
well to be honest I've always been one
that's like what are the rules okay [ __ ]
those rules
um so I I that's part of it is like oh
wait this is a police station I'm gonna
get high in a police station
um which I may or may not have done
anyway
um but you know like that's just part of
who I am is like the like you know what
let's [ __ ] it like let's try this and so
that was where I was and I think I was
also
I just wanted so desperately to not be
famous
at school I just wanted to walk by and
not hear Whispers of conversation about
me you know one of the things that you
learn in 12-step programs and all this
stuff is you know and you're like people
are not thinking about you
but in my case a lot of times people
yeah I could see that for sure I would
show I would go to a new school and 40
kids would follow me around and half of
them were being nice and half of them
weren't this is what I wanted to ask you
I imagine that makes it really hard to
figure out who is authentic and who
isn't and it's probably very difficult
to make real friends in high school
after coming off of a show like that you
know it is but I will say
um I don't know if I'm
maybe stupidly optimistic or um
maybe just a little dumb but I always
believe the best in people
so I come I I come to most people with a
pretty open heart
um and I've gotten burned a lot and I've
I've trusted a lot of the wrong people
but I try to not let that stop me from
being who I am
um and yeah I mean people are shitty
people are shitty in high school I was
shitty in high school I did really you
know I did really shitty things to
people and hurt people's feelings
because I was you know 15 and an [ __ ]
I have a 14 year old now by the way and
that nothing's changed they're still all
I love my daughter to death but like you
know he was just like there is a world
around you child and I go oh
yeah my mom said that to me too
um but you know I just I desperately
wanted to be like everyone else and so
it was like let me be badder than you
let me be bolder than you but let me
also be smarter than you
and get away with [ __ ] because I gotta
keep up that facade too
in order to get what I want you know
what I mean like it was a it was a lot
and I like I've only recently I think in
my like late 30s and now 40 have started
like pulling the threads apart isn't it
a while it's [ __ ] crazy I mean like
I'm actually working on yourself at
never stops it's true and I'm in a real
period I'm excited to do this show
because I'm in this real period of um
growth and
um
like creativity and trying new things
and being open and
raw and honest and just kind of who
exactly who I am and let radical
self-acceptance
so um it's exciting to get to come on a
show like this and you know talk about
who you really are and figure it out
along the way because like [ __ ] if
you're really doing it it's like you
said it's you're always just like oh
you're not right every time either
you're like oh [ __ ] I was wrong about
that or you like you do something and
you're like oh that oh God that worked
for nothing right that was terrible
right that backfired yeah and it's and
like it's such a process and being um
being patient with ourselves in that
process because I am an inpatient person
and I my yeah my biggest challenge in
therapy is that I will show up week to
week and be like you know I'm sorry that
we're still on this thing about like my
childhood and she's like it's been three
weeks like you're not gonna and I'm like
I know but I should be over it by now
and she's like that's how this works you
know so I yeah I expect instant results
and uh that's not it's not how
self-discovery Works guys it sure isn't
it takes a long time to [ __ ] you up and
it takes a long time to unbuck yourself
yeah yeah just as long as it takes to
get yourself wrapped up in it liquid IV
fuels your well-being with easy ways to
stay hydrated every day I've been
hitting the gym now I dropped my liquid
IV right in that bottle Shake It Up take
it with me stay hydrated all day one
stick of liquid IV in 16 ounces of water
hydrates you two times faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
five essential vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 and
vitamin C and with three times the
electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks it's made with premium
ingredients non-GMO and free from gluten
dairy and soy to date liquid IV is
donated over 25 million servings in 50
plus countries around the world grab
your liquid IV and bulk nationwide at
Costco or or get 15 off when you go to
liquid iv.com and use the code honeydew
it checkout that's 15 off of anything
you order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code honeydew at
liquid iv.com that's promo code honeydew
at liquid iv.com you ever get the
feeling that someone's watching you like
even when there's no one else in the
room now I know you're probably thinking
it's Halloween season I'm just being
paranoid but this is actually real every
single day there's actually someone
watching your every move the worst part
is you're even paying them to spy on you
that someone is your internet service
provider every website you visited late
at night how much time you spend on each
they're keeping tabs on you and that's
why I use expressvpn if you use the
internet we all do expressvpn is an app
that you just need to be using internet
service providers are legally allowed to
sell all their users browsing activity
to advertisers with expressvpn 100 of
your traffic is rerouted through their
encrypted server so no one can see a
thing my favorite part is expressvpn is
so simple to use you just open up the
app you tap the button and that's it
expressvpn works on all your devices
whether you browse the internet on your
phone tablet computer you can use up to
five devices at the same time under one
expressvpn subscription look I want to
say this I travel the continent I travel
the country I'm constantly using it to
get Sports in different cities uh in
Canada we used it to to for payments and
things so stop letting people invade
your privacy right now get three extra
months of expressvpn for free when you
go to expressvpn.com honeydew that's
expressvpn.com
honeydew expressvpn.com honeydew to
learn more now let's get back to the do
all right so when you're drinking in
high school are you drinking with
friends or is this like a thing you're
just doing both
it's like all
drink everybody
uh I had no off switch and I always like
that's the stupid ideas abound can I ask
you I sit across some people who tell me
they're alcoholics and and because I I
can have a beer I can have half a beer
and leave it and they're like I can't no
it's the point and they say like if I
have one I'm gonna have 20 and they're
they'll say that's not an exaggeration
so is it like that for you don't have an
off switch you know what I realized with
alcohol is that
for me it um
it just triggers something to where
there's like there's no off switch and
when I look at it you know one of the
things that it talks about in the
literature of of 12-step books is it
says you know our our goal is to drink
like a gentleman it's an outdated book
it's from the 30s but
uh you know our goal is to drink like a
gentleman I and I had to get real honest
with myself and in my program and when I
really came to the conclusion that like
oh I don't want to drink like a
gentleman I want to get to obliterated
as quickly as possible or right to the
edge of it to where I'm at least still
upright you know what I mean like that I
want to get there and stay there when I
drink and so once I realized that
it was a much clearer thing where I was
like oh yeah it's not appealing to me
the glass of wine isn't appealing to me
because because that's not a glass to me
that's three bottles in because that's
where we're gonna go so so when do drugs
enter Then if alcohol's 13 when did
drugs come in I mean probably like 14 15
smoking pot on the way to school you
know
um it wasn't until I like graduated my
my grad night of high school was the
first time I ever tried uh ecstasy that
was the first night that I did anything
like harder than smoking pot and I I I
smoke pot and I never really liked it
when I was in high school I don't know
why it would make me really dizzy and
like puke it was just puke really yeah
it was never like I didn't love it in
high school
um and so
anyway so that was the first time I I
did that and then I was like that was
awesome
um and
you know I was going through a lot of
drinking at that time I my parents were
really worried about me what's a lot
what was the day I mean well my parents
didn't know but it was like it wasn't
even like a daily thing it was just like
if I had an opportunity to go out of the
house or go out with friends I was doing
something [ __ ] stupid like the cops
brought me home one night I lost my
brand new car one night we lost it well
I gave it to a friend of mine uh who
actually had a suspended license who
wound up driving it to San Diego and
returning it two days later but I didn't
know that because when I handed in the
keys I was in such a blackout that I
didn't remember who I handed my keys to
and it was a brand new BMW so yeah this
is this is the [ __ ] that I do it like
like lay down in the middle of the
street traffic it lands like that stupid
[ __ ] movie like that's the kind of
[ __ ] I do uh-huh like oh let me stand on
the you know ledge of a seven-story
balcony and see if I can bet like that's
used to be okay yeah yeah yeah that in
my 20s that's the stupid [ __ ] that I do
because
so it's more than just getting drunk
then oh it's also the risk of uh bodily
in death yeah I think it was
um you know for me drinking and using
um
it and it started then at like 1718
um I really started getting heavy into
my drinking and using I
um would occasionally get cocaine and
Ecstasy but again mostly just alcohol
and what was your drink of choice
whatever you had it didn't matter
whiskey or I mean whiskey I loved that
but like I you know you didn't care
I have Bacardi 151 contest like we you
know whatever yeah that I don't when you
win that there's no winning that there's
not it's not a win it's not it's not
three shots of that in a row is not a
win for anyone particularly your
intestines anyway
um
but you know by 1718 uh I had a 0.9 GPA
in school I was uh and I was on in on an
academic scholarship I went to a you
know Chapman University I went to a
great school
um I was smart you know but I just
didn't go to class I was just drinking
all the time
and my parents when I graduated high
school my parents were terrified uh of
me going because I was getting into so
much trouble and
um
the deal that we struck was okay well I
live in the dorms because I was like I
have to have the dorm experience
and the goal the the deal was that I'd
stay in the dorms through the week while
I was at class and then on weekends I
would have to come home okay and be at
home I could go out with friends but I
had to stay at home at my parents house
because it was only like 20 minutes this
was their attempt
so I was like word Monday through
Thursday party time Friday Saturday
we're gonna rest up and that's exactly
what I did and I did not go to any
classes I broke my ankle
the third day of school running down a
flight of stairs
um which then turned into this crazy
[ __ ] rumor that I was on acid and
thought I could fly and you know Jody's
been murdering no I was running down the
stairs and I overestimated because I had
had a few beers and I stabbed my ankle
but I didn't want to that was at night I
didn't want to get it looked at so I
stuffed it in a tennis shoe and I walked
around on it uh I didn't want to admit
that I'd broken it
but I wouldn't go to class but I would
certainly go to uh drink so that was my
priority and um
by the time I
had entered into I think it was the
second semester of my freshman year of
college
um I was dating
the man who would become my first
husband
um and
everyone was really worried about me my
roommate I I'll never forget my roommate
once saying to me she came in the room
and I was drunk again people were there
and whatever and she was just
heartbroken
because she picked me up so many times
or come to find me so many times or
worried when I disappeared so many times
and she just said if you take one more
drink like I done with you and I just
looked it right in the eye and I was
like cheers [ __ ] and drank it
and that's the kind of person I am when
I drink and
um you know that was where I was at in
college I um and I've talked briefly
about this before but I started cutting
I was a selfie I was a self-harmer what
brought that on
I have learned
in so many years of therapy uh but I
have learned that um you know it's it's
an outward physical expression of mental
pain when you have this overwhelming
feeling that you don't it's like your
brain goes I don't know what to do with
this like if this happens at least I can
be like oh that hurts okay so it's a you
want to feel you want right it's like
you want to oh that I can do this yeah
yeah so you know I never any never
anything like super deep I didn't but I
uh you know was almost getting kicked
out of the dorms for being a danger to
myself my parents were really worried
um I would come home and just sleep for
like you know 30 hours straight
um
and I was not doing well and at that
point I was 18 years old and
um
I was out one night and um like I said
the guy that I eventually married the
first time uh he picked me up and we
were driving down PCH somewhere and we
pulled over and
um and he called my mom
and he handed me the phone and he was
like you need to talk to your mom
and I was just like
okay and uh and that was it that was the
moment that I I
the first moment
the first moment that I was like I need
help and something's wrong okay and I
went home for a couple weeks well no it
wasn't a couple weeks it was like a week
um and just kind of tried to detox and
figure things out and
um I decided I was gonna move out of the
dorms that I just was it was not the
right situation for me
um and
I went back to my first class that night
and uh I was taking a class called
Western mysticism and spirituality which
was this really interesting class taught
by this really awesome priest dude and
um
I came back to class that night and that
night we just happened to be studying
the spiritual principles of the 12 steps
and we had two people from Alcoholics
Anonymous come show up and tell their
story and
I sat there and it was the first time
that I heard
the way that I felt in someone else
interesting and she was an older woman
and it was this and her husband and they
were like you know in their late 50s
early 60s they looked nothing like me I
lived completely different life but I
heard
how I felt and uh they left that room
and I chased them down the hallway and I
just turned to her and I said I need
help
and she told me to meet her at a meeting
the next day and that was the very first
time I ever went to a 12-step meeting I
was 18 years old that was the first time
I tried to get sober okay and uh you
know it getting sober for me was a
process it was up it was down I um I
graduated school I got married like I
said I was uh how were you when you
first 20 years old when I got married
first I was very young
um I thought and my my first husband was
a great guy
um but I was I wasn't done yet I I
was holding on for everyone else but I I
I had done some of the work but not deep
enough I I had some more digging to do
to get down a little further
and um and so you know my 20s uh I I
relapsed while I was married I was
married to a police officer I was doing
a lot of drugs and a lot of stupid [ __ ]
while Americans I was doing speed I was
doing ecstasy I was doing cocaine I was
doing a lot of stuff and hiding it from
him yeah a police officer yeah
is how would you hide it
he worked at night ah he worked at night
so I could go out at night and then he'd
come home and sleep during the day and
then I could go do you know I I during
the day I would be home doing stuff
whatever you know again
um this was one of those things that
I've had to look at where I go oh I was
doing that pretending thing again
where I was
getting the you know being the perfect
wife and cooking meals and doing all
this stuff and redecorating a house and
you know getting a job and blah blah
blah but I was also over here doing this
you really were you were able to do that
for a while a couple years
and eventually that ended uh poorly and
I just got honest and I went to
treatment for the first time
and
you know that was uh I was so
terrified
I was so terrified uh
I was like 22 almost 23 and I was like I
just [ __ ] everything up like
everything
um
but I but I had experience like I knew I
remember on the way home from uh the
hospital
um the night that everything blew up
with by using and drinking I remember
just seeing the serenity prayer over and
over again
which is you know God grant me the
serenity except the things I cannot
change the courage change the things I
can and the wisdom to know the
difference and the entire car ride home
which was a silent car ride with uh my
police officer husband and um you know
all of the news
um
I just said that over and over again in
my head because I knew that whatever
wherever I was going after this I it was
the decisions had been made the the the
the freight train had come crashing down
to a halt and now we pick up the pieces
and it'll be okay
you can do this you know and
um and again I went through treatment
and I was gonna work there and I was a
star student and doing great and then I
relapsed you know but I hit it and then
I would you know and again I found I I
have found this element of
let me be star student
and then let me but let me also sabotage
myself
um and
you know I spent my 20s I finally was
like [ __ ] this like I left treatment for
a while I was in sober living I was like
I can get an apartment by myself this is
gonna be a great idea and I relapsed
immediately
probably over a dude because that was
also what we were doing in treatment
because like you're bored so you're just
like you're [ __ ] up you'll do
um
and yeah I mean look I've uh
um and so
you know I just I I like I was real
messy went back to treatment was really
angry
I could it's so funny for you like years
I my memory would not bring up the name
of the place that I went when I went to
treatment the second time it was like I
blocked that entire
time of 30 days out of my mind and I was
like I had to like go back and really
reprocess that and think about it
because I I was just really angry
um
and then you know I and then I I got
divorced obviously and then I was out
partying and I was going crazy and life
was whatever and then I met I just won
your mid-20s my mid-20s yeah 24 25 I
for a long time I've talked about this
before didn't expect to see 30. you
really I really did the way I was going
and I don't think anybody around me did
either
um you know my parents my God my poor
parents
um who left me through all of it but who
you know eventually would hold
boundaries and be like yeah please don't
come to Thanksgiving
um
you know I
I was really lucky that I had them there
but I made it I just blew up every area
of My Life um and then you know and then
I of course I've met someone else I met
someone and everything's gonna be great
now
um and I knew them for six weeks and and
then we were with friends and there was
like a you know someone was like we're
gonna get married too I was like oh
we'll totally do it too we'll get
married and that was exactly how I made
the decision and then we got married and
my parents found out through my agent
and it was awful within six weeks yes
where did you get married like Vegas
yeah we got married in Vegas
um he is the dad to my older daughter
and he and I get along very well now
um we have been through our hell
um and yeah and that was you know we got
married and then I and then I got
pregnant
and all of a sudden
um
responsibility oh [ __ ] it's real now and
I was like oh [ __ ] what do I do you know
I I I I had to figure out what I wanted
to do and I
I thought maybe this is
maybe this is my opportunity to to
do it right to heal something and so
um I you know I went through with it I
was really excited and of course now my
daughter's 14 and she's [ __ ] gorgeous
and amazing and like I love hanging out
with her
um but it was really overwhelming to go
from being a complete [ __ ] mess
to having a kid and being married and
living you know we moved out to a house
out in Corona which is like you know an
hour and a half outside of La
um all the friends I had were all like
party friends so I didn't really have
anybody I wasn't working he wasn't work
like we were just it was
I was completely overwhelmed you know
when I started drinking again
um and then I then I knew I had to get
sober
um really quickly after that because I
all of a sudden
it came full circle to me
the resentment and anger and hurt that I
had with my biological mom and all these
years that I had spent thinking
that it was me or that I wasn't worthy
or that like
I don't know somehow hanging on to some
bit of why did you do this why did you
make me this way
you know why why did you pass this
stupid [ __ ] Gene down to me
um
and in that moment I realized
that
I wanted to stop drinking and was having
a problem and loved my daughter
more than anything in the world and
nothing changed that but I also had this
problem
and suddenly there was this like level
of forgiveness
and understanding of someone who was
just very very sick
and that I didn't have to be that person
and uh
and it changed me you know being a mom
really really changed me
um did you go cold turkey that first
time like right when you got pregnant or
did you just stop yeah yeah I mean there
were a couple I think I had like a glass
of wine here and there but like it was
you know it went from like [ __ ] let's
rage this [ __ ] to like oh what yeah you
know people were definitely surprised
people were like you're doing what yeah
they doubted you huh well I the people I
was hanging out with were like oh so
you're not gonna so I shouldn't call you
to get high now no no you know and it
was like what do I do on a Tuesday night
like I'm going out to clubs like what
you know life got very different
um and I'm so grateful for it it I it
saved me
I probably saw 30 because of it
um and in it and I had a whole different
perspective
now things didn't work out with her dad
and I we split when uh she was about
four and a half months old
um that didn't work out it was ugly for
a while now we're cool and we're friends
and we like laugh about like remember
when I [ __ ] hated you
um which I hope everyone can get to that
point with their ex remember when you
were that [ __ ] and I did this yeah
yeah man or like you know somebody
something will happen we'll be like I
didn't I didn't slash retire I swear to
God
yeah you gotta defend yourself
like I I may everyone get to that point
in a with their ex because he and I can
travel together and show up for our
daughter and it's amazing and I'm really
proud of that
um you know we may have our differences
and whatever but I know at the end of
the day like
from what that was and how we met and
how [ __ ] up I was at the time and
everything we've done pretty damn well
and we got a great kid yeah you know
um and so uh but at you know after that
obviously I was like okay I was divorced
that's not happening
and that was like two like two years
later and you know I met somebody else
and of course this is the thing that's
gonna fix it and this is the issue real
quick that was uh I know you did that so
quick but did you get an annulled or did
you no no we went through a divorce it
was ugly it was custody it was no fun it
was articles in the paper it was you
know all of the [ __ ]
um it was expensive
um you know it was all of those things I
was it was as ugly as divorce can be uh
plus you know public and TMZ [ __ ]
um and because it was so close to you
know
um dealing with my addiction and my
treatment and because in some of the you
know divorce proceedings it was talking
about me trying to get sober like it was
this salacious thing so it was you know
it was no fun
um and then anyway I met someone else uh
I was sober things were going well and
we had been together for a while and you
know again I I've got pregnant and
we we're like you know maybe we don't
have to get married I don't know maybe
we do we're I was like I'm okay with it
we don't have to we don't have to yet
um and I got my adorable daughter B who
um came out like a little fuzzy peach
and she is this interesting creative
wonderful girl
um and you know her dad and I then
eventually got married and it was it was
we were kind of like well I mean
insurance is coming we should do this I
mean we got a kid like I guess you know
why not
um again also not great reasons to get
married
um and you know and it's we we were
together it was it worked at the time
and I think
I realized I never asked myself the
right questions when I got into
relationships like what
I was actually talking about this today
that uh I whatever I wanted
didn't matter it was I knew I could put
my needs aside to make someone else
happy so I wasn't gonna make any demands
or ask any questions or have any needs
or wants because
I I can push mine to the side and it's
easier to make someone else happy and I
did that a lot
um and
you know I did that and then
unfortunately I wound up in situations
where I was really unhappy
and
that wasn't the other person's fault you
know they didn't know like you know they
have no idea I read somewhere too that
women break up with men in their heads
six months before they actually leave
six months is that is so true let me
[ __ ] tell you everything
about every time right now every time
every time
is broken up with you they've been
looking at you for six months going this
[ __ ] hate with hate when he's like
that oh my God yeah and then they're
like but I can't leave yet because I got
this guy oh we're going on that trip in
June
all right you know what I'm gonna stay
okay I'm gonna say I'm gonna stay but
[ __ ] this guy and you're playing
emotional invisible hangman and like
maybe if I'm being nice
some shoes
okay fine you get a shoelace you know
what I mean and then finally I'm just
like that's it I'm done [ __ ] this let's
burn it to the ground and you know the
other is like huh what just happened
um and you know and and
again I wound up divorced and I was
working in treatment and I had now I had
two kids and now I had no money and I
managed to be getting divorced while I
was working in treatment
um I had to be out of the condo that we
shared
um into someplace else the treatment
center that I worked at got taken over
by one of the investors I got fired I
had no money I have had an old car that
um you know his dad had given me uh and
I had no idea what I was gonna do and
um the owners of I was living in one of
the bottom Apartments of one of the
sober livings with my kids when all this
happened I lost my job and everything
and suddenly I so then you lose your
place too I suddenly lost my place I
suddenly lost my job I mean I was making
you know twenty two hundred dollars a
month
um I lost my job I lost that I was in
the middle of an ugly divorce
um I had two kids and I had no idea what
I was gonna do
and how old are you at this point this
was when I was
30
usually one ten [ __ ] lifetimes before
that yeah it was like 31 I'm 40 now so
this is you know within the last 10
years of my life
um and
you know and and I wound up Landing a
dear friend of mine wound up leaving his
apartment and going somewhere else he
was like I'm gonna be gone for three
months take my place
and I wound up Landing in this little
apartment building
with my kids in this other person's
apartment with stuff in storage and
suddenly an apartment opened up across
the way
and I begged my parents to co-sign for
it it's terrible credit because I owed
like a hundred thousand dollars to the
government for from back taxes that I
was still trying to pay off
um my credit was like 300 something
legit that's it was not it wasn't bad
credit it was like
wow you [ __ ] that up right
I get a 0.9 GPA I like to get like a 300
somewhere my credit score I like to go
so like that's like I said I want to be
better than everybody
[ __ ] you watch this right yeah hold my
beer is that literally my [ __ ]
sentiment to everything like you gotta
do this now it's hold my coffee
anyway I uh where was I um
oh [ __ ] my train of thought crashed
um anyway I you know by this time I had
two kids and I I I apartment opened the
apartment opened across the way and uh
there we go and so I moved into that
little apartment and it was one of the
first times
that I ever lived on my own
not with someone else right you know
when I was 19 I when I was 17 I moved
into the dorms and moved out of them
after a semester
back to my parents house from my parents
house I bought a house at 19 and I moved
into it with my then fiance I'd never
had a an alone apartment experience
full time with the kids I had the kids
50 50. we've we I would have them half
the time you know
um I was working again found another job
in treatment
um and you know I've lived this like
normal life like this you know go to
Target and like have to put things back
life
um and
that was it you know I was like seven no
it was ten years ago now
um but that was where I was at and I in
all of that
had to go through this process of
learning how to find joy and be happy
even
if I didn't have the stuff on the
outside to prove it
you know and like I would work in
treatment people like wait aren't you on
TV like why are you working here and I
was like I need a job like why wouldn't
I you know there was I I for me it was
like there was nothing I would wear I
worked for 10 or 12 an hour when I
started in treatment I was taking out
trash and like helping detoxing clients
puke you know what I mean like it was
not glamorous
um but I was willing to start there and
you know eventually I worked up and I
was working in treatment and I was like
okay so this is like my life now and
you're staying clean and sober staying
clean and sober yeah and like life was
really good
um and
you know I had had one relapse at one
point when my younger daughter
um I had been prescribed um pills for a
car accident and so I learned I was like
okay that's I Somas are not uh yeah it
was like a week and I went then I like
couldn't pick up a fork and I was like
oh yeah this is bad
um
at least feed yourself right if you
can't do that you might have a problem
um so anyway but but I had you know I
had time at this point I was working in
treatment everything and
um
suddenly I so I was working at this
place and
you know I get this call that they're
wanting to pitch Fuller house
John's they're wanting to bring it back
they feel like there's an audience that
you know Candace is into it Andrea's
into it they want to base it on the
three girls John wants to produce like
all and so the pieces are kind of
falling into place as far as like
wanting to go out pitches and we all
meet about it I'm like sure what the
hell so I'm like living this normal life
and like I'd have to miss work to go to
a pitch and
you know there was like a month there
where we were going we went to ABC
family we went to ABC we went to TBS we
went to all these places uh and they
were like well I don't know that we want
to you know bring back something this
was before reboots were like the thing
everyone did
and uh
we had this horrible meeting
that I actually couldn't make it to I
had a huge meeting
um for for regular work my my civilian
life that day John couldn't make it
Andrea and Candace like went to the
wrong address for Nickelodeon it was a
total [ __ ] show of a of a pitch but at
that meeting
was
um Brian and I can't think of his name
right now I want to say Grazer but I
think I'm wrong uh who left and then
went to Netflix
and brought the idea of Fuller house
there and said hey you guys they're
pitching this thing and we went in to
meet with Netflix like a couple like a
month and a half later they were like it
was the last meeting
and we all went we were like it was kind
of a Hail Mary like okay sure you know I
mean it went well whatever
and
then suddenly
we got the call a little while later
that like Hey we're gonna pick up the
show
and I was like wait I what
oh
wow okay
oh like I get to go back to
that again so let's talk about a 5 to 13
you're in entertainment 13 until how old
are you when you get the call that this
is gonna happen well I still stayed in
entertainment I did I was still in
entertainment like there was I think I
shot a um a holiday movie at one point
when I was working in treatment like
like you over a month I shot it so like
I still kind of had a toe in it okay I
did episodes of I did like six episodes
of Party of Five I did you know guest
appearances on Yes dear and a few other
things so I was still in it throughout
my 20s I did like acting intensives and
all that kind of stuff I was still in it
but I had to it was at that point I had
to move on to other things to pay the
bills yeah uh you know I had child
support I had [ __ ] attorney fees
attorneys fees I had rent I had you know
um I had kids and I also had no ego
about trying something new and starting
at the bottom and like okay I went back
to I went back to school I got my you
know a certificate to be a drug and
alcohol counselor that was what I wanted
to do I wanted to go back and become an
mft or LCSW
um so anyway I all of a sudden this got
dropped in my lap and
it was
it came at a point in my life that I was
ready for it
and I knew that I could
truly appreciate what I had
um
yeah man walking back on that set
what was I like
it was incredible at 13 years old you
know I'll never forget it 13 years old
taking that final bow it gutted me
I sobbed much like I did on Fuller house
you know it
but at that time when I was 13 and I was
sobbing I was sobbing because I was I
knew I was gonna miss these people and I
knew that I that the routine that I had
had my entire life that from when I
could remember basically
I all of a sudden didn't have that
anymore it was gone and you know my
parents had always been like remember
this doesn't last forever like tried to
you know prepare you for that but even
as an adult there's nothing that really
prepares you for like this is a huge
loss and so that really [ __ ] me up I
think and also no one even in your
family or most of your friends couldn't
even relate to what no nobody's doing or
going no nobody could had hindsight for
that nobody there was no experience for
that no there was no nothing to to
relate to or understand or you know and
it and and even for myself I was like
well I feel silly like if why am I so
upset over this you know as an adult now
I look back and it's like dude you were
like mourning a huge loss like that's a
big deal
um so anyway
coming back to that set
after leaving it at 13 and I mean I
could I could go on a visual tour of
that like same set almost there were
some and it was funny it was like
walking into your childhood home that
somebody else has lived in and they've
done some remodeling but like it's kind
of the bones are basically the same and
like most of the stuff's the same but
like that wasn't there like oh you guys
added a bathroom over here and like oh
that the Alcove was bigger or like you
know what I mean like the certain things
where you were like oh I just
I know that how so well
that I know it was four steps from here
to there and not two you know or
whatever
um but for the most part it was
the same
and I remember walking on Set uh after
we did our table reading with cast and
we all walked on there together
and that was amazing
did you take time to appreciate like the
full circle that it just appreciate I
know it's full house but I know it's so
I know I know but no you know what it is
but but the gaps between 13 and there
everything you had gone through to lead
you right back to here now how about
that it was the modern age of tech
digital and everything who would ever
seen it coming back again and in a way
that it did you know it was huge and
that that was a bit like no I
I mean God I've sobbed at the end of
um Fuller two and there's actually a
beautiful picture that I cherish where I
am hugging Andrea and Candace and it's a
picture of my back and I'm hugging them
in the Full House living room and Bob is
standing in the background he's just
looking like this and it's one of the I
have it I've posted it it's one of my
favorite photos
um because it says a lot there's a lot
of there's 30 some odd years of family
history in that photo and um
being able to come full circle and then
I did Dancing with the Stars which you
know look it sounds silly I used to go
to ballroom dance competitions in my 20s
and watch I love them I like I always
wanted to do that any competition show
I've done
I've only done because it was something
that I thought that I wanted to learn
how to do before and so if I'm gonna get
paid to do it and play for charity shirt
[ __ ] it
so I did Dancing with the Stars and then
like I started working I did I had
another show that I produced and was
like writing on and starring and called
Hollywood Darlings which was a really
fun Improv based sort of Curb Your
Enthusiasm type show with um Christine
Lakin and Beverly Mitchell about being
former child stars in Hollywood and
continuing to work and but I started
moving more into like adult comedy
outside of Full House and and then
finding my own voice and finding what
that is and that's kind of where I'm at
in my journey right now is like
stretching out a little bit doing some
more fun comedy stuff writing a little
bit here and there
um leaning into the Persona of myself
um and liking who I am outside of just
being that girl from Full House yeah
[ __ ] yeah all right I want to ask you I
feel like I've rambled on I give the
world's longest [ __ ] answers I feel
like you this here and then this is just
me I'm I'm gonna just call it out in
like my head because my head is like
you have bored them all so I hope I
didn't bore you okay please this is your
episode you told me to be quiet and wait
till you hear this [ __ ] and I sat here
and listened yeah I mean but I have
questions okay yeah yeah well let's get
to the question who tells you about your
biological father's murder in prison is
that your adoptive parent that was my
adopted parent yeah when because I you
know I mean the glaring question where
was I from where what who you know what
happened
um and I was mature and I understood
quite quite a bit you know what I mean I
was not like a typical 11 year old I
yeah I was able to kind of understand
things and process things I mean you
know again well as well as an 11 year
old can but my parents were very honest
with me which I don't regret and I
respect very much because
I I they on top of the [ __ ] that I
was processing
the fact that they had lied to me was
never something that was in there
and I'm grateful for that some parents I
think try and like blow it off or not
tell them the truth or whatever because
they don't want to hurt them or are
afraid that they can't handle it at a
young age and I think there's a way to
do it that
allows you to be honest because if that
would have been the case like that would
have been yet one more you know thing
um what about your biological mom did
you ever connect with her I never did
and I learned recently that she passed
in 2013
um
I don't know how uh you know and it's
weird
um I know I found out through oh it was
through I think it was
maybe ancestry or so I did a little
digging because I did like the 23andMe
because I was like what the [ __ ] am I uh
I am the uh potentially the whitest
person on the planet
um no actually I'm not I really
re-updated it I've got seven percent
wait they already updated it I updated
it and apparently I have seven percent
so that I can be recorded and
potentially send it back to you like hey
we we actually well I'm like English
Irish Sky man look at me I'm just a like
a Nordic [ __ ] English Welsh wet dream
it's just blonde blue-eyed you know but
apparently I have seven percent Italian
that was it but for a while there was it
was like 99.9 just just born as white
people uh but anyway I um I didn't I
found out about her through through I
think ancestry me year 23 and me but
from what I heard
um she you know she struggled her whole
life and I knew she had other kids yeah
she had other kids
um
uh one of whom I recently connected with
who lives on the east coast and I
actually need to call her back um you
have some siblings there's some out
there uh no I knew this is that some of
them were out there
um but uh
you know now through the wonders of DNA
testing you find them um so I've emailed
and talked to one girl that's my half
sister
um who I think looks like me
um or I look like her because I think
she's a little older uh
but yeah I you know she lives a hard
life my uh the story that I have and
what I know in the small bits of
paperwork and things that I have
um and the the story that my parents
were told by the social worker was just
that she you know she had been her own
really since she was 15 been on the
streets
um kind of did what she had to do to
survive
and
um you know got caught up in like drugs
and bad checks and trying to just keep
things together changed her name a lot
you know was trying to know if she
raised any of her children I don't know
if she did I don't believe she did uh
there was a woman who contacted me who
was a foster parent
um and I think she had another one or
two of her kids I think one maybe
um so I think there's like at least
three or four
so um I don't know but I you know and
it's funny because I
you know
I went from
being angry at her to being very proud
of her of my biological mom and saying
you know what
you knew your limitations like you you
you know what you you you were doing
what you had to do to survive and you
were with somebody and you got pregnant
and you you know decided to have it but
you knew you couldn't do it and so you
would give up your kid and like in some
ways that's the ultimate
selflessness right is to go I can't do
this for you someone else has to
and um and it once I got to that place
in my life and I got there after having
my own kid I was gonna ask you if being
a moment being a mom shifted everything
like it really shifted everything
because suddenly
you know and it shifted my relationship
with
um my mom
because now and I think that happens
anyway once you get older like all of a
sudden you're like oh [ __ ] like you were
just a person trying to figure this out
too I wonder some sometimes it got a
little [ __ ] up like you were just a
human being trying to have your own
experience and you start seeing your
parents and your family as like whole
people yeah and you're like I only saw
because I know my kids only see the
mom's side of me and I remember my mom
said that to me one time she said you
only see the mom's side of me she was
like trust me when I'm out with my
girlfriends that's my that's the other
side and I was like
oh [ __ ] that's true I will always have a
mother-daughter Dynamic with you you're
always going to be able to look at me
and I can yeah I remember the first time
I saw a teacher out in public and I was
like right you're like oh my God you're
a human person in the classroom right
like you know and as you get older like
and and I think also as you get older
and your parents start telling their
[ __ ] up stories of like oh this one
time I was at a you know Bob Dylan
concert and we smoked weed in this van
but you know you're like oh my God like
you were human too and I've just come to
this greater appreciation
um of my mom
and my parents but particularly my mom
um and everything that she did for me
you know and like
she her entire life was my life
and um I had a great relationship with
her because of that
um but like I my birth mom
gave me a life
beyond my wildest Expectations by being
able to
walk away
you know and that takes that takes a lot
that takes a lot so that's really well
said this has been a really great
episode I appreciate you coming on now
I'm gonna ask you what I told you I was
going to ask you at the beginning advice
you give to your 16 year old self
because it's very interesting time for
you you're just a couple years off of
Full House you're in high school what
advice do you think you would tell
yourself at 16
oh
you're worth more
good for you that's great yeah you're
worth more
uh
yeah I think 16 year old being needed to
hear that
no thank you again for being our guest
on the 200th I am so honored uh to have
come and babbled at you for an extensive
period of time
I loved it and and you know the best
part look I laugh at myself like on
paper I am a [ __ ] disaster I am a a
Thrice divorced
a four-time married two oh you did get
married again I thought I saw that is it
pretty recently too in July July 30th
and I he is he is my person I [ __ ]
love him I finally like finally finally
figured out I finally figured out what I
wanted in a relationship and that I get
to actually show up to it too and like
have a good person and that I'm worth it
I finally figured that out
um but yeah I you know I just recently
got married and uh you know on paper I
like it's not cute like if you write
things down I'm like okay look look the
resume is not the full picture
bring me in for an interview I swear to
God I am a Charming [ __ ] let me
tell you but if you just read it on
paper you're like okay wow treatment
twice drinking at 13. okay you got
married on a dare three times Jesus Oh
two big okay one kid with another person
great got like you go through the thing
and you're like
wow uh but also you live through all I
lived through all of that and I have
some [ __ ] hilarious stories like I
I've got stories for days I'm gonna be
the old crazy lady uh at the dinner
table telling the most inappropriate
stories because I'm 85 and [ __ ] you I
can that's right and you got a ton of
them oh yeah so much time you can come
back and share stories I would love to
yeah I would love to um one more time
please plug and promote everything you'd
like um you can follow me across all
socials at Jody Sweetin
um I am most active on Instagram because
I'm old
um and Tick Tock enthuses me uh no but
I'm most active on there you can check
out my podcast never thought I'd say
this at never thought I'd say this on
social media
um and I will I post everything that I'm
up to on there I've been doing a couple
episodes of Pictionary which actually
really fun hosting that or I'm uh being
one of the team captains on that I've
been just trying trying to stay busy and
doing some fun creative stuff so check
it out at Jody Sweetin and I keep
everything updated on there all right
thank you again I really appreciate it
so glad to be here and uh I can't
believe that I revealed all of that to
um these these wonderful people you did
a great job thanks um as always Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]